[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what i collect is mainly iron man hot
toys and till date now i have about 105
figures
hi i'm terence t i'm 37 years old this
year i'm currently in the real estate
industry
i will display them in certain
order i have arranged like a
iron region which consists of mach 1
till now mark 47
i also will customize certain figures as
per what i want that is that was seen in
the movie
actually for my figures they are not as
precious as some collectors because i
will dismantle them i will display them
i'll play with it i will try to display
individual parts of the ironman figures
like the helmet
the arc reactors the gauntlets the
figures so every pieces look very unique
of course there are some collectors
might think that i went overboard by
destroying a
very expensive figo by dismentoring it
but for me i think that is the passion
of how much i want my display to be
[Music]
as a very impatient collectors i do
customize figures not available in the
market for
customization i will rely on this
ironman manual i have to study what does
the color what is the color
what individual parts consist of then i
gotta go and source for the parts
and then perceive the customization a
single
mark can consist of four figures for
example for this this is mark 13. the
torso will consist of like maybe mach 40
but the shoulder pad will consist of a
max 7.
of course i have to learn how to
aspirate it i got to learn how to attach
things i got to participate i got to
send it off to
achieve that custom that i'm trying to
build it
really do take time and effort the
hardest part is actually about the
masking mask spray a massive and do the
same process for all the rest of the
part attach them back together make sure
everything looks good according to what
was in the manual
of course during this period i did break
certain pieces things that i broke which
i couldn't fix back i will try to put
them into this diorama which i did this
diorama actually consists of all the
figures that i have which i display them
as all those that has already been
perished
like uh thanos gauntlet holding on to
spiderman masks
i have figures of broken shield from
captain america
iron man armor that was being destroyed
most of the avengers figured that i have
all the spare parts i will all put
inside the diorama
so the one that i find most unique about
my display are the holograms because
it's not available on market
thanks to some customizer they have to
cast every individual parts they have to
attach them together and even comes with
a let up
the biggest
figure that i have is the hot toys
iron man mark 44 which is the hulkbuster
it's about 12 kg and it's very detailed
although it's not very plausible
[Music]
this room is basically my
main cave and also my office
so
day time i have to have the discipline
to work uh in this room of course there
are times when i'm talking to my client
i get distracted by the figures but
usually after ten when i stop work uh i
will turn on all the lights that's where
i start to admire the figures
sometimes when a particular figure that
caught my eye i would take it off the
show try to play with it
this plane this way the
most tedious part that collector faced
was to clean up it's about 10k to do up
the display so no choice if you love
this hobby you like to display it the
only way you have to do is also to clean
it up to make the figure looks the most
tip-top condition
as possible i only clean my figures
maybe about twice a year but because
every day i've been touching them so it
will get less dusty
i'm married with two kids and i have
three dogs at home this hobby actually
also has been inculcated as our daily
life
during day time when my kids are home
they will come into this room they'll
look at my display they'll try to spot
is there anything new that i did to the
display even my kids sometimes they know
the particular characters of some of the
figures that i own
my wife has been very supportive she
actually bought me stuff uh like one is
to one war machine bus
she got me a
max 6
bus as well
so they have been very supportive
and i have this dog her name is vinnie
she's very close with me and she's
actually the keeper of my man cave
whenever i'm home she will be inside and
basically she sleeps in this room
i would think that as long hot toys
produce iron man i will be
preparing to purchase it
[Music]
you